[inaudible]
joining me today is the host of the relatable podcast,
a speaker,
a commentator at a cat person,
Allie Stuckey.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you for having me.
All right,
Stuckey.
I have wanted you in the studio for quite some time.
Glad to be here.
It is good to have you here,
but we got,
I got two bones to pick before we do anything to do with cats.
Number one,
you're a cat person.
What's going on?
You just met my dog.
Love about,
she's so sweet.
I love dogs.
I have a dog.
She's a rescue.
I have two cats.
Cats are just,
they're cool and they're easy.
They don't need that much of your time,
that much of your attention.
I travel a lot like you do and so it's nice to just be able to leave the cats,
but you got to put a dog in a Kennel.
You got to pay a bunch of money.
They need your time.
They need your attention.
They need to go outside.
Cats are cool.
They don't really want to hang out with your plotting to kill you.
Most of the Times you're looking at you that they could lunge at you at any
moment.
That's a stereotype that I week expect someone on the left to me,
but that's not true.
You have to take cats by their individual personalities and not categorize them.
Look at how you just used identity politics against me just right.
Right.
It applies to the animal kingdom to,
I just needed you to know.
All right.
That's number one.
Okay.
Just going to have to agree to disagree on cats and dogs.
Number two.
For about two years I had the number one Prager u video.
Oh,
I left the left.
Sorry.
Then you came in there.
You took number one away from me,
but actually I don't know if you know this as of the last,
cause you could see somebody else took number one.
I don't,
I'm not even so we need to get them in here now we have a bone to pick with
them.
Yeah.
I actually can't remember who was,
um,
or what even the topic wasn't sore this morning and I was like,
I don't even want to know.
I don't even want to now.
But you,
uh,
you was,
what was the title of his masculinity?
I think it was like make men masculine naked or something like that.
So I guess that was a hot topic that people really wanted to hear about.
I mean,
it was so fun to make.
Obviously you've made Prager u video too,
but I didn't really anticipate it being one of those viral videos.
I kind of just thought,
okay,
most people in general agree with me,
but the vitriol of course they got you.
You just,
you're continually surprised by some people on the left who are so opposed to
what are very traditional ideas.
So,
yeah.
All right,
well we're going to talk about some of those traditional ideas.
We'll toss,
talk about masculinity and me two and a whole bunch of other stuff called for
people that don't know you.
Yeah.
Where did you come from?
What's going on here?
Yes.
So I started in this whole kind of political,
I won't even say media field,
but kind of about three and a half years ago.
So fall of 2015 I was working in PR,
graduated from college in 2014 PR,
social media just had kind of your normal agency job.
But in fall of 2015 I lived in a college town,
Athens,
Georgia.
And I looked around and the friends that I had,
both in college and out of college had no idea what was going on in the
election.
It was the primaries.
And I thought these are really smart people and a lot of them are conservative
in their values and yet they seem to be touting these progressive use when it
comes to politics and they really have no idea what's going on.
And so I really just kind of had a,
a random idea when I was driving one day called my mom and I said,
you know,
I think I want to tell sorority girls why they should vote in the primaries
because they seem so apathetic.
I feel like I can talk to this crap.
Cause I was a story a girl about a year before that.
And so I created this,
it really was a nonpartisan presentation,
um,
for,
for college students for why they should vote in the primaries.
And I started reaching out to add the sorority presidents and you can find that
information online.
I just said,
can I please come?
I want to speak for free.
It's going to be nonpartisan.
I just want to tell you guys why you should vote in the primaries.
And it worked.
I mean,
I started speaking to some of these groups and then I started getting asked by
other organizations on and off campus,
uh,
to come speak.
And then from that I started a blog and that was called the conservative
millennial,
ditched the nonpartisan thing pretty quickly.
And then after a few months of doing that,
I started making videos and that's kind of what it took off.
So end of 2016 beginning of 2017 is when it probably officially became a career,
started working at the blaze.
And then that changed to,
I moved to CRTV.
That's where I started my podcast.
And that was the beginning of 2018 yes,
I'm getting my years confused.
Beginning of 2018 that I started the podcast,
so still speak,
still commentate.
Um,
I still write.
You still do a lot of the same things I was doing three and a half years ago.
It's just evolved into a full time thing.
Yeah,
it's pretty sweet when you start doing something and next thing you know,
it becomes something,
become something.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Not Bad.
Do you come from a political family or anything?
Did you care about politics before this or was that just your wake up when you
realize nobody knows what they're talking about?
A college?
I would say both ant mostly.
Mostly the second one I grew up in,
I wouldn't say it was an a political home.
I knew we were conservatives and I knew we liked the,
the earliest president that I really remember as George W.
Bush and I was really young during nine 11 and I remember the patriotism that my
parents showed and that we were supposed to show.
I knew we were supporting George W.
Bush and we kind of grew up watching Fox News,
but politics,
it wasn't a discussion that we had at the dinner table necessarily.
I just knew the values that we had.
My parents were entrepreneurs.
They came from very poor families in Arkansas.
They had no money when they got married.
They were 19 and 20 and they really went from nothing and then built a business
and built a life for my brothers.
And for me that was so much better than the ones that they had.
And so the idea of freedom of entrepreneurship,
of not having a cap on your potential was just always really attractive to me.
So there was never a time in college,
high school,
even as a rebellious teenager that I was like,
you know,
more government control actually sounds really good.
It just,
it just never,
never occurred to me that that lead to a better life.
I just always loved the entrepreneurial spirit and the idea of the American
dream that my parents embodied.
So it was more of those values.
Rather than talking about politics,
my dad did become a state representative,
um,
when I was in college,
I think it was 2012 and so yeah,
that probably spurred some interest.
I started probably getting a more knowledgeable and more informed about actually
what was going on.
But yeah,
I would say it's more a lifelong value building thing.
And then by the time I graduated college I was like,
oh my gosh,
I feel like our nation is kind of at a crisis.
How does religion play a role in that?
It plays a huge,
it plays a huge role.
You know,
we hear a lot,
especially from people in the lot,
uh,
that your religious views should have,
have no impact on what you believe politically.
Well,
that's just a false idea of,
of religion and a false idea of your faith.
If the,
if your faith is the center of your life,
which religious people believe that it should be and it's going to affect
everything,
it's going to affect all of your values.
It's going to affect probably how you vote.
Um,
and it's going to affect that the things that you believe in politically and the
way that you think that the country should go.
And so be not only a born again Christian,
but also a Protestant Christian.
Um,
having roots in even the Protestant reformation and how that kind of affected
the,
the movement of the West towards freedom and towards the individual liberty I
think has certainly been a legacy that was passed down to me.
And it all just,
it all has always made sense.
I wish I had like a better journey story of changing my mind,
but the idea of individual liberty and human dignity and all of the rights that
come with that,
it just,
it just always made sense.
The stories that come from a little more of an evolution that they are no more
violence and pain and anger,
but there's Tracy they make for a good story.
Yeah.
They look for a good book.
Perhaps.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Um,
so when you got into the online world and started posting videos,
podcasting and all that,
um,
were you shocked that sort of the tenor and the way people talk about these
things and all that?
Well,
ah,
you know,
when I first started,
when I first started the blog and then I started doing videos,
I mean,
one,
I had no money,
no backers,
no idea what I was doing.
And the,
I mean,
the first videos that I did or in my living room,
I have no makeup on,
no light and using my phone look ridiculous.
Got No views whatsoever.
And so it was after I persisted for a little bit,
sometimes I look back and I'm like,
why did you even persists?
No one was telling you to,
but you did.
And then it's really the first time that you get any kind of attention or
affirmation that you also see the other side of it,
uh,
that you also see the negativity when you're just doing it kind of for yourself.
And for the few people that follow you,
you're like,
this is great.
Everyone loves me.
The three people that follow me,
all of me and my parents and my husband love what I do.
This is great.
But then as soon as something kind of blows up,
yeah,
as they say,
you see the negative side of it and you okay.
People don't just disagree with you,
they really hate you and they really think that you're a bad person.
Especially if you espouse any kind of faith that immediately comes into question
if you disagree with them.
And that was hard.
I mean,
I used to focus on the comments a lot.
You have to stop doing that though.
It's so unhealthy.
So that's kind of a,
that's changed over the past few years.
Definitely.
But uh,
yeah,
I think the hatred threw me for a loop at first.
Yeah.
Well it just sort of comes and you don't really know what to do.
And then at some point,
I think I've come around to the place where it's like the more I get,
I'm like,
oh,
I must be doing something right.
Yeah.
People used to lie about what I was saying and I didn't like that.
Now they actually quote me and I'm like,
Oh,
this is actually,
this is what must be feel like when you made it.
I think it was actually you that tweeted the other day,
some article by right wing watch.
It was I you,
yes,
they did
call on me not that long ago too.
They quoted something that I said at CRTV and of course everything looks like
it's some hit piece,
but then I read it and I'm like,
that's what I,
that's what I said.
I was like,
this is an actual basically an honest piece.
Right.
They were really close as quoted show.
Exactly.
And I'm like,
if people think that's crazy,
I'm totally fine with that.
But like you said,
don't lie about the lie about what I'm saying.
Right?
Yeah.
Is it unique to be a woman in this space?
Use the little identity politics here.
I thought Republicans and the right,
I thought they hate women.
You don't listen to women,
don't they subjugate women
who are pregnant,
but you know,
but
she goes and so I am.
I've against that part of that.
No,
I,
I've never,
I've never really understood that argument.
I guess if you equate women's rights to abortion and to this mythical gender
wage gap that needs to somehow be filled by the government,
if you equate women's rights to that and women's empowerment did that then sure.
Um,
I guess the left is the only place for women.
But if you believe in entrepreneurship,
if you believe in the marketplace,
if you believe that women have the potential and the dignity that a man has and
the potential to do everything that a man does in a way,
at least as far as her career goes and leadership goes,
then I don't see why you wouldn't be a conservative.
Unfortunately,
we do have a PR problem,
uh,
on the right,
and I voted for president Trump,
but president Trump doesn't really help the rights case when it comes to women,
not just because of things he said and done with women.
But also I think a lot of moms especially hear him talk,
hear him at his rallies,
he's got a little bit of a of a mouth and they're like,
I don't,
you know,
I don't really want my kids listening to that.
That's not who I want my kids to be.
I wouldn't marry someone like that.
And so I do think that he makes it a little bit difficult sometimes to make the
case.
Is that the odd catch 22 of almost everything Trump does?
Cause we talked about this briefly right before we started where it's like the
policies pretty much make sense.
And if you can remove that from the tweets or the person,
it's like he's actually at a ton of high level women in the administration.
If you care,
if that's what you're looking at,
it just makes it more difficult,
I think that you're able to
do it.
But when the left has such a monopoly on media megaphones,
when they have a monopoly on Hollywood,
they have a monopoly on academia.
I won't say monopoly,
but they're controlling a lot of the messaging that comes out and they're,
they're good at PR,
they're good at the emotionalism that,
not to be sexist,
but appeals to a lot of women.
And so you hear the rhetoric of Trump is putting kids in cages and he grabs
women by the genitals and you're a woman.
You're like,
I can't vote for that.
I can't do that.
And so in order to separate some of the lies from the truth and separate the
things that Trump has said from the good things that he's done for men and
women,
you have to think,
and you have to go a step further.
You have to do your own research.
And a lot of people,
male or female,
just don't want to do that.
When you can read headlines by just swiping your thumb,
why are you going to take the time to actually click on an article and then
double check it and make sure that it's right?
It's just harder to be a conservative for that very reason.
It takes more effort.
How do you cut through the clutter?
I mean,
that's one of the things that,
especially when I go to colleges,
that kids ask me all the time like,
how do you actually figure out what's true?
Because reading all of these articles,
it's like,
I mean,
we know because they write them about us and then it's like,
well,
I know what lies that were in there.
So what else?
What else are they lying to us about?
I mean,
you really have to try and go to the source if you can.
If they said that someone says something,
you have to actually go to the actual quote or the actual video.
I mean,
a perfect example of this is when president Trump,
uh,
just the other day,
the clip of him saying or allegedly saying that asylum seekers we're animals
with circulating.
Great.
Yeah.
It was deceptively edited.
And so in order for you,
someone like Chrissy Tiegen who tweeted about it and said that,
you know,
he's awful.
Okay.
In order for you not to believe Chrissy Tiegen for in order for you to not
believe the tweets that she quote tweeted,
you're several Democratic candidates by the way.
Yes,
yes.
Also,
so it's not just Hollywood celebrities,
even though they knew he wasn't,
just to be very clear here,
he was not saying that asylum seeker,
Mcgregor animals,
he was specifically talking about Ms.
Yeah.
Which is a totally appropriate description of them.
Um,
but in order to realize that that's a lie,
you have to jump through a lot of hoops.
I mean,
because say I'm someone on the laughter Sam,
someone in the middle and I see Dave Rubin or Ben Shapiro say,
that's not really what he said.
Well,
why should I believe you anymore?
So you have to go to the actual source.
You have to go to actual reporting.
It's more effort.
That's something that you and I are probably willing to do because we know the
game that they're playing.
But a lot of people just don't know.
But I also think that's why people are turning away.
Um,
especially young people from mainstream media and from talking had to listening
to podcasts where there's conversations and when there's dialogue where there's
nuance and where people are willing to say,
you know,
I don't know that much about this.
Here's what both sides are saying.
You hardly ever see that on the news.
So I think,
I think that's part of it.
It's a change in the media landscape.
Yeah.
Where do you think Trump fits in?
I try not to do that much about Trump in general,
but since you brought him up.
Yeah.
Um,
where do think he fits in with sort of the future of conservatism then is I can
sense a little push and pull with you on him.
Yeah.
I mean I voted for him and I think I'll vote for him again.
It's mostly because I voted for him in 2016 mostly because lesser of two evils
then I didn't think that he was going to lead very conservatively.
I mean,
especially prolife,
it's a huge issue for me at,
he had just a few years earlier,
said he was pro choice.
He didn't seem to emulate any of the conservative or Christian value is that I
hold in my life.
But then I looked at Hillary Clinton and I looked at how I felt like the country
was torn apart by Barack Obama over the past eight years.
And I was like,
okay,
someone who is going to probably advocate for legislation and surround himself
with people that aligns more with my values or someone who I think is
diametrically opposed policywise to everything I believe.
So I chose him and I think I would choose him again because again,
I,
not that I would ever vote Democrat and I've never been on the left.
But if I were,
say I were a centrist,
I would be looking over to the left and saying,
okay,
this guy don't like what he says,
don't like his personality.
I think he's too brash and sometimes he doesn't make any sense.
He calls Tim Cook Tim Apple.
Okay.
Yeah.
Like he's a little embarrassing.
But then I will get people who are advocating for late term abortion,
open borders and socialism.
And I'm like,
oh,
like my babies and my private property,
I think I'm gonna stick with Trump.
And so yeah,
I'm even more so in that camp because I am a conservative and I do care about
the future of the country and I hate socialism.
So of course I'm going to vote for him again.
And I think that's how a lot of people feel sometimes a hard case to make.
Yeah,
that's how I see it.
I mean,
it's like if you guys could just not be that bananas,
they can then the refugees who wouldn't do it leaving you,
but you just can't not be completely insane.
No,
they give us something here.
Well sometimes I wonder if it's a strategy.
Are they taking us to the nth degree?
Are they taking us to the,
the most crazy Marxism that they can actually take us?
Are they taking us to,
for example,
medicare for all,
just so we'll get on board with healthcare for all.
Are they taking us to open borders just so we'll be okay with abolishing ice?
Are they taking us to,
you know,
killing babies outside of the womb to where we can say,
okay,
as long as limited the second trimester.
Because I,
I mean,
I don't think that's going to work,
but I do wonder,
are you guys pushing us to the limits?
So we'll settle for something a little bit less,
but that's still liberal.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I mean not,
I suppose that could,
well,
you know,
I don't know what the answer is,
but I suppose they could be doing,
I mean,
Trump does a little of that,
right?
Yes.
Take out something really far and then you come in.
I mean,
that's what negotiations,
you're right.
Yeah.
I don't know.
But watching these guys go off the deep end has been quite something.
And so I mentioned to you a couple of days ago on,
uh,
on Twitter.
So you've been hitting the AOC pretty hard.
And I think your arguments,
you never attack or personally you always go for policy or for the,
the context of what she's talking about.
Yeah.
Um,
tell me a little bit about why you're not thrilled with AOC.
Well,
we hear a lot of people in the last sane,
oh,
AOC gets tea.
All,
she's really getting into y'all,
she really bothers you.
And I'm like,
yes,
she really does.
I'm not even going to pretend like she does it,
especially bothering me.
She specially bothers me because she is representative of millennials,
which she isn't really,
but she's representative of the stereotypes of millennials and she's a woman and
so she is claiming to represent all millennials and all women and she is
espousing and saying everything that is so diametrically opposed,
not only to what I believe in,
but what is good for America and also like she just says dumb things.
Just dumb.
It's not that okay.
She's crazy.
Like I think Bernie Sanders is crazy,
but I think he's probably smart.
Like he can make a pretty good argument.
She just isn't good.
She's not even good at fulfilling her own arguments and I think it's her.
It's the hypocrisy to of same.
Well,
no one has any legitimate concerns with me.
No one has any legitimate criticism.
I'm going to pull this random tweet from this person with 10 followers and say,
well,
this is all of the right,
making fun of my shoes.
This is all they've got.
We'll know.
There's been a lot of people asking you for dialogue and debate and to discuss
ideas and policies and you refuse to,
that's what bothers me.
Yeah.
So what do we do about that?
Because the energy of the media,
the focus,
so much of it is on her.
I agree.
I don't think she's particularly bright.
I think she has handlers that at times are writing her.
She's not writing most of these tweets.
Yes,
maybe she types them out,
but it's very clear if you listen to her speak the way she speaks and her
understanding of information is very loose.
And then in Twitter form,
she knows all these things about history and policy and all of these things and
the idea that she wrote the green deal or any of that stuff.
It's just all nonsense.
But what do you do if so much of the energy is focused there?
Um,
which I,
you know,
I think we're in agreement.
It's dangerous.
How do you move that if she won't debate?
Yeah.
I think that all you can do is advocate for your own policies and ideas the best
way that you can.
And yes,
of course,
to call out her lies and say,
this is why it's a lie.
I mean,
you might not convince everyone,
but maybe there is one person who thought that her tweet was awesome and looked
at what you said and said,
okay,
well maybe now I am starting to see a pattern of not just her,
but people like her that use identity politics and use,
uh,
this victimhood narrative.
Someone like Ilhan Omar as well to say,
Oh,
you can't criticize me.
I'm seeing that a lot.
Maybe her credibility comes into question.
So I do think that's important.
I think it's important to keep it above board as much as we can with the
criticisms.
Now I'm not necessarily good at that.
Like sometimes I just want to,
yeah.
And I don't,
I don't want to call it,
I mean,
I don't think I ever go for anything super personal or ad Hominine,
but there are times where I just want to be like,
this girl's an idiot.
She's an idiot.
And I don't think that that's probably just to call myself out.
I don't think that's the most productive thing to do.
We should probably say why she's wrong.
Um,
but someone who I think is actually trying to play her same game,
um,
it's a little bit different cause he's older and he's a man.
But Dan Crinshaw is using social media to his benefit to actually talk about
what's going on in Congress.
Say,
here's the legislation I'm trying to get past here for the Democrats are doing,
here's the back and forth fight.
We have hardly any transparency in Congress from the right.
We don't have a young representative that saying,
okay,
this is what you're hearing.
Here's what's actually happening.
AOC is trying to do that.
But you do have someone like Dan Crenshaw who trying to do it on our side.
And I think that's important.
What do you think is the goal of this new crop of Democrats?
Like do you like,
to me,
they genuinely want to change every fundamental law and every fundamental
philosophy that is underpinned this country for over 200 years.
I mean,
really it sounds alarmist.
It sounds conspiratorial,
but I think they're deeply on proud of what America is.
Yeah.
Um,
and it's very sad for me as we talked about right before we started,
it's like this ain't the party at JFK anymore.
Right?
It was one thing when we just disagreed on policy.
It's another thing when we disagree on patriotism,
it's when we disagree that fundamentally America was founded on good ideas.
Maybe you don't like the founder founding fathers,
maybe you don't even like that they owned slaves.
Maybe you think that America has a bad history.
We can probably agree on that.
That America doesn't have a perfect history but us not agreeing on basic
constitutional values of individual liberty,
of the rates that are endowed to us by our creator.
That creates a whole other host of problems.
We have not more complicated disagreements between this new crop,
but a more fundamental disagreements,
more simple disagreements than we've ever had before.
That's what makes them so frustrated.
And,
and people like me,
like us who care about American values and are down with the constitution,
it's really kind of mind boggling.
Like we don't even know where to take their arguments sometimes.
But when you look at what's coming out of academia,
I mean all this postmodern garbage,
it kind of makes sense.
I mean,
they've been taught that America is this imperialist aggressor in everywhere.
Boots have been on American boots had been on the ground.
Uh,
evil has spread and white nationalism has spread.
That's what they're learning.
You're like,
okay,
I can see where they got that.
It's sad because it's an accurate.
Um,
but I think that's kind of where it's coming from and that's what they're
promulgating.
Yeah.
Are there parts of their right that you're not happy with?
It definitely.
I mean,
if the old rate is even still a thing,
I feel like it's kind of had its heyday.
I literally prayed that it's had.
Of course,
I don't like them.
I think there are a bunch of Internet trolls.
There are people also who think that the world,
the West is going to be one back through memes.
I don't think there's anything wrong with me.
No,
they're all good means no.
I thought that was the cause or anything wrong with that.
But I don't think that's primarily where the,
where the battle is flat and then I do get frustrated with people who can't ever
criticize Trump when he says things.
For example,
and this was a while ago saying,
okay,
we'll take away their guns and then due process or something like that,
or where they can't refute him on trade,
they can't push back at him at all or they try to paint him into like this
almost Demi God savior.
That bothers me because,
okay,
let's not pretend that he's Ronald Reagan.
He might've even done better things than Ronald Reagan in a lot of ways,
but let's not pretend that who he is as a man is Ronald Reagan,
that he represents all of our conservative values.
I think it's okay to say,
you know what?
As a Christian,
I don't really agree with a lot of things that he says.
A lot of the things that he's done,
I still like his policies,
but I'm just going to be honest.
I don't love everything that he's done.
The people that will not say that,
that bothers me,
I just don't get it.
Do you think that there's a like sort of a sickness around the Culta personality
related to our politicians,
the way we talk about them and think about them.
I mean,
so you could take that with Trump from certain people,
you know,
the certain just die hard mag of people who would never find fault and you could
take that with the obsession with,
oh there's better with his shirt rolled up,
standing on auditable and skateboarding and just the way we talk about them,
like they're all celebrities or that,
that they have the where with all to fix all our problems.
It all actually feels gross to me.
Like politics feels very gross to me for someone that talks about it as much as
I should.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's because it's gotten so dramatize that it almost feels like
our favorite soap opera.
You know how someone has a character that they just love and can do no wrong.
They're like,
I'm,
I'm fighting for this person in this show.
It's almost that are our politics have become so celebritize,
which really almost started with Barack Obama and so dramatize that people have
picked their favorite characters and they feel like they have to pick one and
there's,
there's no way.
Yeah,
there's no way that they're going to pick the other one.
But I also think it has to do with the fact that they see their enemy as so bad,
as so crazy as so radical and the left is beating up on Trump so much and so
unfairly that they,
they,
I think they're honestly thinking and maybe with good intentions,
why would I pile on that?
Sure.
Maybe I don't like some of the stuff that he does,
but we never hear any of the good that he does.
So I'm going to be a part of the group that talks about the good that he does
and not the bad.
So maybe,
maybe those intentions are pure.
Yeah.
So I,
I do agree with that.
I think that there's a certain set of people that think,
well,
wait a minute,
this guy is relentlessly getting attacked and lied about and Russia
investigations that everything else.
So when he says something like to me the the one that you hit on a,
we'll take away the guns first and then the due process.
To me that probably is the worst thing that he has said in,
in the two plus years.
Yeah.
And I could see why a decent person that would know that that's wrong wouldn't
go crazy about it because a,
he probably was probably just like sloppy language maybe.
Right?
Maybe,
but B,
it's like everyone's attacking the guy constantly.
Like cut him some slack.
But I guess that does it.
There's a danger in that too.
Yeah,
and I think it's that they look at his actions,
they keep saying,
or I should say we,
we look at his actions like,
do I think that he is ideologically prolife?
Do I think he really cares about abortion?
Probably not now.
Maybe he's been awakened to like a lot of people have with the New York law and
the Virginia Bill that didn't get passed and said,
okay,
that's really bad,
but I don't really care what he personally thinks about abortion.
He's been a prolife advocate and I think that's a good thing and I want him to
advocate for the things that I believe in.
And I always knew when I was always pretty confident in the fact that even if
he's not an idea log,
which I think we all knew that he wasn't,
he was going to surround himself by people that would push the values and the
policies that conservatives believe in him.
That's nowadays,
that's really all I care about.
It's almost all,
I wouldn't say all,
but that's most of what I care about enough to get my vote.
So is that the irony I guess for Christian conservatives is that you needed a
guy that was going to do a play,
a dirty game and,
and maybe you couldn't get Romney or McCain.
Yeah,
I mean tried it the other way.
Like those guys weren't going to play in such a way because it's not just that
you're fighting the candidate.
You're also fighting the media establishment in the colleges and all that.
That's not how I thought of it,
because I didn't vote for him in the primaries.
In Lichen,
in the primaries,
I actively talked about not voting for him in the primaries,
and I honestly didn't understand.